So people who have specific phobias are not necessarily more generally anxious
than other people. In fact, they're only really afraid of their feared and
phobic object. But they really do go to great lengths to avoid these phobic
situations or objects. So for instance, someone might be afraid of elevators.
And what that means is that they will go to great lengths to avoid elevators.
So they make sure that their doctor's office or their dentist office or a hotel
room is always on a lower level so they can get to by stairs. Now this
treatment for these situations and these phobias is very fascinating. But we're
going to save that for the next lesson. Now what causes specific phobias? Like
all mental disorders, as it turns out, it's a combination of genetic and
environment factors. So for instance, a person who has a specific phobia very
often has the genetic disposition. But they also may have low levels of this
neurotransmitter called GABA. They may have personality disorders like
narcissism. And finally, they often are exposed to really chronic stressful
situations in their lives.